la vice présidente et son équipe ont
passé l'après-midi à essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
une étudiante d'une vingtaine d'années
en licence 1 est décédé d'une maladie
fulgurante dans la nuit on leur est
conduite à l'hôpital hier après midi
dans un cas comme ça la première
explication qui vient c'est la méningite
or celle ci est très contagieuse les
étudiants ont donc été contacté
préventivement mais peu avant 18 heures
le verdict de la rs tombe ce n'est pas
une méningite
nous avons la douleur est de constater
le décès de chaîne étudiante de campus
universitaires la grèce donc à
investiguer et les résultats des
investigations démontrent très
clairement qu'il ne s'agit pas de cas de
méningite je voudrais rassurer
l'ensemble des étudiants de la
communauté universitaire des personnels
qui pourrait en fait avoir à côtoyer
cette cette jeune fille notre notre
jeune étudiante
il n'ya pas donc deux cas de méningite
concernant ces décès on ne sait pas
encore ce qu'il ya au juste causer la
mort de cette jeune fille il n'y a donc
pas de nécessité de quarantaine mais une
cellule de soutien psychologique sera
mise en place pour les camarades de la
jeune étudiante qui résidait au crous